it is a real honor to be with you today
I used to his Ian just said preach every
Sunday but one of the things that you
discover when you become a Dean and I
was a Dean at Notre Dame is in your
first year you lose your time in your
second year you lose your creativity and
in the third year you lose your mind so
the good news is I'm only in my first
year here the bad news is I was a Dean
for a number of years before I got here
there's a story about a 19th century
minister in Palmyra Missouri named Jacob
Creek Jr who was renowned for the
fervent see with which he prayed and one
particular occasion during the Civil War
his town was surrounded by troops and he
went out as was his custom to a
particular grove to pray he got down on
his knees and just white-headed old man
I've seen a picture of him long hair
full beard just poured his heart out to
God on behalf of his neighbor's his
family his entire town his country and
above all prayed for peace and according
to the story the commander of the troops
was doing reconnaissance and heard
someone speaking rather loudly and crept
up and saw him praying and was so moved
by this prayer that he withdrew his
troops now I can't verify if that
actually happened you may be wondering
well did that really happen that's the
question I asked but whether it happened
or not it teaches us a truth about
ourselves in our relationship with God
and I feel some of the same way about
the text this morning that are the
stories that we've just heard if you ask
me
these things happen precisely as the
third evangelist narrates them I have to
say I don't really know but if you ask
me are they true i will say emphatically
yes and that's what i'd like to think
with you about for a few minutes the
stories begin with Jesus going up onto a
mountain to pray seemed like a very
simple framing device that sets up the
stories until we realize that the third
evangelist routinely marks every major
event of Jesus's life by portraying
Jesus at prayer Jesus is at prayer in
his baptism when the spirit descends
upon him he goes up onto a mountain and
spends an entire night in prayer before
he chooses the 12 he is again at prayer
before he asked the disciples who do
crowd say that I am and then who do you
think I am when Peter made his momentous
confession he is at prayer here before
his glory is revealed he will be at
prayer before he teaches the Our Father
he will again be at prayer in Gethsemane
when he contemplated his immediate
future and he will pray from the cross
why did the third evangelist present
Jesus praying prior to all of these
major events in his life it's a unique
emphasis mark doesn't have it Matthew
doesn't have it the fourth evangelist
doesn't have it why does the third
evangelist emphasize jesus' at prayer
the third evangelist is unique in the
sense that he not only wrote a gospel
and i say he because the personal
pronouns in greek are in the masculine
so it's not an incorrect political slept
just repeating what the text says here
but the third evangelist bright the Acts
of the Apostles as well and thinks of
Christianity as expanding over a wide
horizon of time you don't write the
history of the church if you think the
world is going to end tomorrow and
because of that the third evangelist is
concerned with how do we sustain faith
over our entire lives and so the
Evangelist introduced the parable of the
widow and the judge with these words
then Jesus told them a parable about
their need to pray always and not to
lose heart and concluded it with and yet
when the Son of Man comes will he find
faith on earth faith is sustained
through prayer Jesus has held out as a
paradigm of one who found his own life
with God sustained through his prayer
and through his conversations with God
and so will we but what was the event in
this case what's clearly a revelation of
Jesus in glory the text says his face
change his clothes became dazzlingly
white they saw his glory Moses and
Elijah appeared with him in glory and
then a cloud a symbol of the Divine
Presence overcame the group and
encompassed them but what's the
significance of seeing Jesus in glory
why narrate this the traditional reading
is to say well it's simply an event at
the end of jesus's Galilean ministry one
way to read it others have said Peter
had a vision like Joan of Arc and this
is a record of Peters vision most modern
scholars will say something like
this is actually a post-resurrection
appearance that has been brought up into
the text so that we have a proleptic
understanding of jesus' glory and there
are still others who will say it's a
symbolic way of describing Jesus at his
second coming but however one might
explain the origin of the story it has a
clear function the story is a means of
allowing the disciples and us as those
who hear the story about the disciples
to see the glory of Jesus at a pivotal
moment in his career his ministry in
Galilee is now over he in 951 turns his
face steadfastly to go to Jerusalem
where he's just told his disciples he
will be executed and where Elijah Moses
and Elijah have talked to him about his
departure which is to be fulfilled and
yet for Luke the story is not just about
his death but about his resurrection and
his ascension which this evangelist
narrates this evangelist used at death
as a human verdict leveled against Jesus
that God overturns by the resurrection
in glory so unlike the fourth gospel
which views the lifting up on the cross
as a moment of Jesus's glory this is a
way of saying God overturns the human
verdict by giving Jesus an exalted state
in glory this text allows us understand
who Jesus is before he goes through his
death and that's why it's here the
disciples are rather slow to get this I
don't think they could have gotten into
Yale they struggle with trying to figure
out who Jesus is but the subsequent
story shows them and even poor
alight it is a story of a father meeting
Jesus as he comes down from the mountain
a father who has a son who as the text
says his demon possessed or we would say
is struggling with the neurological
disorder people might say epilepsy maybe
maybe another disorder but the father
had asked the other disciples heal my
son and they couldn't do it and as he
spoke to Jesus his son had what we might
describe as a grand mal seizure and
jesus healed it I can understand the
plight of this father in a very personal
way when my older daughter was a senior
in high school she developed a
neurological disorder it resulted in
events that were similar to but not
identical with seizures one day when she
had one of these attacks in the hospital
she cried out to me and I can see the
scene in my mind very clearly dad make
them stop make them stop and there was
nothing I could do I was doing
everything I could by having her in the
hospital eventually I took her to the
Medical Center in Chicago and they said
that a virus had made its way into her
spinal column and wreak havoc with her
nervous system said it will eventually
dissipate and it did and today she's on
the faculty at the University of
wisconsin-madison very healthy adult for
which I'm very grateful but I however
can never read this story without
identifying with the father when he said
I begged your disciples to cast it out
but they could not now why are these two
stories juxtaposed
why have the story of Jesus in glory
juxtaposed with this poor father who
wants his son healed one of the greatest
Renaissance painters understood this
quite well I think Raphael whose
Transfiguration was commissioned by Pope
Clement the seventh at the time he was
only a cardinal he later became Plymouth
the seven as an altarpiece for their not
bone Cathedral Raphael worked on it off
and on for four years but died before he
completed it but if you've ever seen it
it has two scenes an upper scene and a
lower seen the upper seen is the
Transfiguration the background are
clouds that are luminous with the sun
shining and reflecting on them very
clear the lower half is very dark and
chaotic and i think that the goethe
understood exactly what Raphael was
depicting when he said this about that
painting the two are one below suffering
need above effective power sucker each
bearing on the other both interacting
with one another whether we hear the
stories in the Gospel of Luke or whether
we see the painting of Raphael the point
remains the same we are all reduced to
human frailty at times and forced to ask
to whom
can I turn and the answer of these texts
the answer of Raphael the answer of
Jacob creath is all one in the same we
turn to the risen and glorified Lord